i want to go back in time to something
that that ian said you mentioned that um
even within someone's race there's great
diversity
well ian i bring you now to a story from
bounding into comics
mcu fans claim casting sochil gomez as
america chavez's colorist harass actress
for being too light-skinned wrong
ethnicity well so there you have it ian
yes you are correct within different
colored people there's great diversity
but they don't want that
they want
they want simultaneously someone who
looks just like the person in the comic
while also saying that you can have a
black woman play like anne boleyn or
something
my attitude is honestly i don't care who
plays a character like when idris alba
was um
what's the guy's name in marvel that
with the eyes you can see oh i can't i
can't remember
who's the guy who can see everything in
in marvel i don't know he's the norse
god yeah yeah i know and people are
complaining because it's clearly
endorsement it's based on norse
mythology and he's not uh and he's not
exactly as pale as the
as the other ones and i'm one of those
people that i don't have a problem with
the race swapping as well
especially if i don't have a strong
connection to the source material
heimdall heimdall but so so people
there's a lot of people who are like
it's norse mythology and heimdall is a
white man i'm like dude he's an actor i
don't care like there are some instances
where i can certainly understand it if
you're like
you know that one's a little too much
when people complain about anne boleyn
being played by a black because it's a
real person right it's a historical
figure
i still kind of don't care that much
because i don't i don't i i want
someone's performance to to yeah the
best athlete and i want you to play
martin luther king jr yes well there
lies the point i can make that happen
they will they right now the woke are
complaining that sochil gomez is is the
wrong color yes but they're also the
same people who complain that or state
that you can have a black person play a
white character the little mermaid is
now yes uh but it only goes one
direction it only goes wonders because
they don't actually believe what they
believe and they are harassing the crap
out of this girl and it's like i feel so
bad i'm really young actually interested
in your experience now sorry to cut you
off there bro i want to yeah uh you were
there i mean yeah i mean um this is a
pretty new phenomenon in hollywood right
and so you go back in time and you see
movies from 10 years ago when someone
did something like this and now they're
getting sort of canceled for it but the
worst the worst case was scarlett
johansson
her attachment was going to get a movie
made about the trans about a trans
person and and i think
you know those types of movies can be
helpful
in uh normalizing a behavior pattern
things like that whether you believe in
it or not i'm just saying it's a fact
and her star power
and so and so the the trans activist
came out uh uh cancelled the movie
and now this movie is not going to get
made yeah ever uh uh there isn't a
foreign sales driving trans name
now you could say well okay hold it back
until there is one uh yeah that's not
going to happen 15 years
you know her name recognition drives the
ability for that movie to make profit
and and and benedict cumberbatch uh you
know playing a gay man it's all these
different things it's so exhausting so
again just the the reason why
and i don't want the rules but once the
rules are created them's the rules so so
look look at this real quick it's this
this twitter user claudia amandabar says
oh whitewashed america as i am so sorry
what they did to you
what
like literally what i don't understand
read some of the other ones further down
yeah
well
they get more insane who attack
who attacked her though was it the aaron
rupars of the world or was it the well
you know who who who made the first okay
america chavez is a strong confident
queer afro-boracuo
with queer biological parents and
afro-buriqua adoptive parents i do not
know who this variant and doctor strange
is supposed to be but it's not the
character whose stories i've been
reading for a decade okay so when people
complain that heimdall was played by a
black character i would like to see you
say the same thing now me personally i
don't care that heimdall was played with
i think idris elba is fantastic they
talked about many people were like idris
elba should play james bond i'm like
he'd actually be a really great james
he'd be great but the problem is these
people are acting in bad faith
they would not say like daniel craig
would be a great you know black panther
they would never say that nope because
they don't actually believe what they're
saying they're just racist lunatics i
would do the first half of my career in
the theater and it was very much about
like anyone can play any role is the
ideas like give actors a chance the best
actor should have the position then i
got into film and it was a different
different mentality it was more about
you want to be as realistic as possible
so if the person's supposed to be an
african-american you know descent dark
skin and it's not then it's very
confusing the film
i like how you pointed out like when
you're portraying real people it's a
very different thing than portraying a
comic book character or a movie
character and i get the people who don't
like it when the when the actual
characters get changed i get the the
dislike of race swapping but it just
doesn't bother me the same way it
bothers other people is it have you
found it to be different what are we
gonna say well i just love when the left
eats itself i mean this is such a this
is such a cell phone look at she's she's
got the lgbtq flag pin on her chest and
she's being canceled yeah this poor
actress gomez is is no right winger
you know
uh scarlett johansson is no right winger
this is this is just this is just
pathetic look you want it you want the
one that cast her in that role is
somebody else
there's a tweet up there where they said
these actors need to be better about not
accepting roles yes they're telling you
that you need to look at this and say
this opportunity could feed my family or
in her age like just could set me up
through college yeah and i need to pass
on that because of ideological reasons
do you remember when just recently peter
dinklage came out and said they're
making snow white in the seven dwarves i
mean really think about what that means
and i'm and and then a whole bunch of uh
uh actors little people actors came out
and they were like you're taking our
jobs from us
roles in a decade yes seven
disney movie roles opened up for could
have been amazing
i think we found out
at a minimum a hundred thousand dollars
each person he pulled the ladder up
behind him he had he's a tremendous
career he's a great actor he was in big
movies he was in game of thrones and now
he's like stop the only reason he was
cast as tyrion lannister is because
lannis tyrion is a a little is it's con
it's like a is that character in the
book and so they said we want someone to
fill that role how about we just get a
regular guy to play that character if we
can if it doesn't matter who plays who
it's all acting well what what what
movie is funnier than elf so that scene
in elf is so good and it's just and he
was and he was he was hired for it great
in it
so i think ian mentioned this
and we i looked it up i recommend you
not look it up but uh we were like snow
white and the seven dudes it's real
it's real it's an adult it's not what i
thought it was no i just thought you
could change the name you know i
downloaded the wrong snow whatsoever
girls can be dudes too when you when so
disney's talking about changing the
story somehow no they they had already
they found out they'd done that
beforehand so they had already
anticipated that this was going to be a
problem before they even went into
production and they're going to make it
seven magical creatures all cgi
so a bunch of unicorns a large list of
people are going to get paid just a lot
smaller amounts on the s on the special
effects uh
cast list but like a unicorn a dragon
like what do you what is it what is it
the snow white and the seven magical
that's all they know so far is like it
was never going to be is lord of the
rings canceled because dwarves does not
reference little people it's a reference
to
magical creatures like elves are we
going to complain about elves being too
tall there's dwarf with a big d which is
fine but it's the little d dwarves that
you can't say because that's yeah
uh lord of the rings is grandfathered in
if it was a brand new project no way
well you know why it's not grandfathered
in no it's not
because it's a new project look have you
ever looked at the thing that's like the
ginger side and it's all the redheaded
characters that have been removed and
replaced with yeah so it's like that's
what's going on right now like like what
they did with the little mermaid they've
recast a little mermaid uh so all of
these stories are not grandfathered in
you're going to suffer either way here's
here's what i'll add to this so chill
gomez story america chavez
she was given the role of a queer woman
of color who's wearing an lgbtq pin
and now she is being attacked for it you
know what the ramifications of this will
be no one will ever want to play a a
character that represents a marginalized
group because it'll damage their career
like scarlett johansson like sochil
gomez and you know what they're doing it
to themselves this means in the future
they're going to be like we've got a
great character for the superhero film
who turns out to be a gay guy i was
gonna be like no i'm not going anywhere
near that sorry
whenever whenever they were uh releasing
being the ricardos which is a fine movie
it's okay
uh there was a lot of talk about javier
bardem playing desi arnaz and there is
this amazing article in uh the hollywood
reporter where aaron sorkin talks about
all of the different folks the
diversity coordinators that he brought
on to set
so that he could get away with casting
javier vardam as desi arnaz
she was incredible do you remember what
they did to when you mentioned gina
carano earlier when she had her when she
got fired from disney but before they
fired her uh they tried to do have her
do a 40-person struggle session with
members of the lgbtq community on a zoom
call like that she said she said i'll do
it in person i'll talk to these people
one by one in person in an auditorium
i'm not gonna be bullied by 40 people on
a zoom call that's insane yeah i
wouldn't do it i'm gonna sit here and
start my camera and be like dude but the
average actor you said she's brave the
average actor's like yeah you can abuse
me for the next hour that's right if
gina carrano was an mma fighter yeah
yeah she's uh she's seen some stuff
she's not scared she's taken a punch in
her day and that that's something to be
said you know often one of the things i
bring up with this um
you know you mentioned people crying
about donald trump winning the election
and you're like what is what is this i'm
like well look
if uh um if you've never been in the sun
you'll get sunburned so these people are
soft little you know blobs of of pink
jello
and then some other people have dealt
with hardship someone like gina carrano
who's trained and fought and had to deal
with injuries and getting punched in the
face is going to shrug off the stupidity
of words
someone who's grown up in a pastel safe
room with padded walls and bean bags al
all their lives will step outside
quivering and shaking and then when
someone says a naughty word like i'm
being attacked it's violence a lot of my
friends from high school uh none have
went to the military really except for
one guy and i in the time i was like
please don't i was so afraid for him
because i thought he was gonna get hurt
and i didn't want it but now today he's
the most aware
like doesn't care about the stupid stuff
he's fully engaged in like what matters
because he suck combat once you see
combat there's no joke there's
you know mma in the military are both
like that if you like when all the stuff
happened with joe rogan the amount of
mma fighters that came out in support of
him because they they understand they
understand that you cannot just let
these people bully you well it's like
when you get punched in the face you
kind of realize some things don't matter
all that much you know you when when
you've dealt with real hardship and if
gina hadn't done what she did
then there would be ten other people who
came after her and showed courage that
never would have been able to do it had
she not had the courage in that moment
and it was the way you encourage her to
do it right away absolutely that daily
wire interview was like three days later
right it was it was about a week later
but but it was it was it was as fast as
we could do it but the announcement of
the movie came literally within 72 hours
or even less 36 hours even and uh you
know it's it we we tend gina and i talk
a lot a lot about being the flak jacket
right walking out there talk coming on
shows like this talking about our our
careers what we've been through
and taking the bullets and showing
courage in many ways i'm not saying i'm
courageous but i'm saying
in in order to give other people courage
to come out and come work with us and
let their american flag fly
i think humility is so important because
if you can embarrass yourself in front
of people that's courageous man thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast if you want to
watch live you can check out this
channel monday through friday at 8pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you